today on the matt welsh show as many
states go back into lockdown mode and
the holiday season is effectively
cancelled due to covid
we're told that those who resist these
measures or refuse to follow them
are in denial about the danger but i
think the people who want to keep
society shut down for fear of a virus
are the ones in denial i'll explain why
also five headlines including the latest
democrat politician to violate his own
covet restrictions a long list
here's the latest one on it and the
daily beast uncovers a massive scandal
apparently a christian politician tried
to convert
some people to christianity shocking
stuff and in our daily cancellation i
will cancel
canada they've been begging for it for
years
and now the time has come the bell is
tolling for canada
all of that coming up but first you know
um when we find i think
there's so many companies out there as
as conservatives as pro-lifers
uh who are against us working against us
in the culture
and probably a lot of these companies
are companies that you're giving money
to because they're just so many of them
and that's just and it's a big problem
and you know as conservatives we talk
about this all the time and that's why
when you find a company
that that supports us in the culture
it's so important to support them
and that's where the pro-life phone
company charity mobile comes in
with charity mobile five percent of your
monthly plan price
goes to the pro-life pro family charity
of your choice
so you get to decide what company you
want what charity you want to support
uh and on top of supporting this great
cause you're also getting a great
service
new activations and eligible accounts
get a free cell phone with free
activation and free shipping there's no
contracts there's no termination fee
there's a no risk 30 day guarantee so
you're not getting
sucked into anything and also live
customer service
based right here in the usa which is
what we like to hear charity mobile
giving jobs to people in the usa
uh and if you've got kids and you're of
course you're worried about security
and protecting your kids you have the
ability to block use of cellular data
picture messages text messages
whatever it is on any or all of your
accounts
many other perks as well free usage
alerts you get a free app to monitor
your usage pay your bill much more you
can do all of this
having this great service while helping
to build a culture of life in america
by supporting a pro-life phone company
it's just it's it's so important
again we complain about not having
companies that support our values
share our values well here's one and
when when such a company comes along
we got to support them because they
support us so call uh call charity
mobile at 1-877-474-3662 or chat with
them online
at charitymobile.com well
you know nobody likes to think about
death or acknowledge
that one day they will be claimed by it
but we live in a culture where people
are
especially determined to avoid such
thoughts and especially equipped
to avoid them successfully you know
there's a never-ending supply of
distraction a million ways to stave off
death thoughts suffocate them sublimate
them there are whole industries
dedicated to making us look younger feel
younger
pop culture is constantly rehashing the
stories of our childhood
allowing us to relive our youth or at
least pretend that we are
you add to that the pharmaceutical
industry with its cornucopia of pills
to numb our pain extend our lives even
chase
despair away from our minds if ever
anyone does have the audacity to die
even in spite of all these efforts
they'll normally perform the
unsightly act away from view out of
sight in facilities designed
for such purposes it's not that all
these things are bad
in and of themselves i i much prefer to
have hospitals and hospices for the
dying
i'm grateful that many of the drugs at
the pharmacy are available should i need
them
not all of them but many of them but the
combination of modern medicine modern
technology modern entertainment
coupled with the decline of religion and
the rise of secularity
has created a great psychological
barrier
an emotional barrier and on the other
side of that protective shield we're
able to carry on
as if we're immortal as if the reaper
only comes for those who
look at its face now this all may seem
like not
so bad a way to live until the barriers
are broken
our methods of avoidance no longer work
and we are face to face with a reality
that we're not prepared to confront and
this is a moment that was always
destined to happen to everyone you know
the doctor calls with the mri results
you feel a lump in a place where there
shouldn't be one a close family member
is
taken from you suddenly by car accident
or suicide or
anything else everyone at some point has
their wake-up call when death
knocks on a door that they have no
choice but to answer
but what happens when an entire society
of death thought avoiders
have their barriers broken all at once
what happens when there's a knock on
everyone's door at the same time
that might have been an interesting
thought experiment a year ago but now we
know the answer the coronavirus has
forced
everyone to acknowledge our mortality
and the response from many of us
was to of course first we remember panic
emptying grocery store shelves for no
reason causing shortages of supplies
that have nothing to do with protecting
us from the virus
and then we erected new barriers
physical ones retreating behind masks
into our homes we're great many
americans have shown an incredible
willingness
to remain for as long as possible it's
not as though
the risk that most of us face is very
high for you know anyone who's not
already sick or very old the chance of
being hospitalized from the virus is low
the chance of dying from it is
extremely low when you look at the
percentages but
it's also a threat in a different way
it's a threat to the the peace of mind
the false sense of security the illusion
of immortality
harbored by many americans this i think
is the great dividing line the
difference
between those who have responded to the
pandemic by retreating
entirely from their normal lives hiding
in their homes wearing masks even just
to walk down the street
and even now still having no desire to
go back to normal no no matter the in
the economic impact that all this has
has had um and and you know those who
have basically continued
so there's that on them one side and
then on the other side you have those
who have basically continued living
their lives
almost as normal uh taking reasonable
precautions but not allowing themselves
to be paralyzed by fear
i think the people in the former group
accuse the people in the latter group
of being deniers they're denying science
they're denying reality
they're in denial it's said but i think
the opposite is the case
these are the people who are not in
denial they already knew they were
mortal they already knew
that they would die one day they don't
want to die now they have no direct
plans to
they are taking precautions but they
understand that their time is limited
their lives are finite
and they intend to make the most of the
time they have
this is why the pandemic didn't throw
this group for a loop
the way it did the other group because
they knew
that these things are part of life they
had already factored that into their
calculus
the truly in denial group are those who
would stay locked down for as long as
they're told
and happily so those who you see wearing
masks as they drive in their cars by
themselves
those who raise no objection at all to
government measures that are decimating
entire industries
putting millions out of work tearing up
the constitution in the process
they're in denial about many things
science certainly among them
but the thing they most wish to deny is
their mortality
and the inevitability of their own
physical demise
this is a point that comes to mind with
the holidays approaching and
the discussion about whether to be you
know with with family around the
holidays
i hear from a lot of people who say that
they're doing the right thing
by declining to be with their families
in particular their elderly parents or
their grandparents
because it'd be too dangerous and of
course if any family member chooses not
to be involved in your holiday
festivities
that's a choice you should respect
nobody's saying you should kidnap granny
and force her to come to your house and
eat turkey
but if your relatives want to see you
for the holidays especially your elderly
relatives
consider the fact just consider the fact
that they probably don't have many
holidays left
regardless of covet we all have a
limited time on this earth
and as you get into the later stages of
life that time is even more limited
it may not be worth it to someone who is
elderly to give up one of their few
remaining thanksgivings and christmases
in order to avoid the minimal risk
involved in seeing their families
they may want to live their lives now to
the fullest extent they can
rather than stay hidden away not every
elderly person will feel this way not
every person in general feels this way
as we already discussed
but we have assumed during this whole
ordeal
that it is is better to keep the elderly
indefinitely isolated to protect them
and certainly we need to protect them we
need to do a better job of protecting
them than they did in new york and so
many other states
but it pains me to think that so many
have lived their final stage of life
alone isolated even died alone
all in the name of safety there's a
balance here that
we have to strike we haven't even tried
to strike it though we've gone entirely
to one extreme end of the spectrum
as if protecting ourselves and loved
ones from kobit kovid is the ultimate
good and no other consideration
should ever be made it's a tragic
mistake i think
on many levels and this is just one
of those levels let's get to our five
headlines
[Music]
all right so who's the latest politician
to violate his own covet rules
and get caught for doing it important
qualifier here you know that is
get caught for doing it because we can
assume that they're all violating the
rules
it's just that they don't all get caught
so the latest is governor gavin newsom
in california
um he went to a party at a restaurant
so that's two levels here what he went
to a restaurant
and it was a party um and uh and i guess
he was caught people found out about it
and here he is pretending to be contrite
a few weeks ago i was asked to go to a
friend's 50th birthday my wife and i
friend that i've known for almost 20
years and uh
and a friend that had well put a lot of
time and energy into his 50th birthday
it was in napa which was in the orange
status relatively
loose compared to some other counties it
was
to be an outdoor restaurant and we
started the well the program started at
four o'clock it was one of those early
reservations i got there a little bit
late at 4 30.
and as soon as i sat down at the larger
table i realized it was a little larger
group
than i had anticipated and i made a bad
mistake
instead of sitting down i should have
stood up and walked back got in my car
and drove back
to my house instead i chose to sit there
with my wife
and a number of other couples that were
outside the household
you can quibble about the guidelines et
cetera et cetera but the spirit
of what i'm preaching all the time was
contradicted and i got to own that and
so i want to apologize to you
because i need to preach and practice
not just preach and not practice and
i've done my best to do that
uh we're all human we all fall short
sometimes
i saw somebody on twitter point out that
there's a real disconnect
um really in general with this guy but
especially in that clip you just watched
between his facial expressions and what
he's saying
he's he's supposed to be apologetic but
you don't see that on his face
uh it keeps saying well we all you know
i made a mistake we all make mistakes
yeah sure we all do make mistakes but
going to a party
while at the same time forbidding the
residents of your state from doing the
same
is not a mistake it's an intentional act
this word mistake is often abused i
think um
a mistake is something you do you didn't
mean to do
right it's it's like an accident if you
do it intentionally it's not a mistake
so this was an intentional act on the
part of the governor
and we have a right to ask what
motivated this intention like it's not
enough with these with these people when
they get caught doing this whether
they're going to get their hair done
or they're going to a party whatever it
is um you see them walking around
without a mask even while they're
lecturing everybody else for not having
masks on
passing mask mandates and everything um
we have a right to
it's not enough to say oh it was a
mistake i'm so sorry okay great you're
sorry you're sorry because you were
caught
but why were you doing it what what what
motivated that we have a right to ask
that
so we could ask with governor newsome
is he suicidal and homicidal does he
really believe that going to an event
like this
might kill someone or himself and he did
it anyway because that's that's the way
he talks
normally if so
you know if he's homicidal and suicidal
that's a fact that might be of some
interest to
the people of california or does he not
really believe what he
says about the virus does he actually
believe that
well sure you mean you you can you can
be you know
pretty safe and go to a restaurant go to
a party like it's possible to do
does it is that is that the case which
means that everything he's been saying
about the virus publicly he doesn't
really mean
it's got to be one of those right it's
either he doesn't he doesn't believe
what he's been saying about the virus or
he does believe it
and he's got a death wish it really has
to be one or the other
and uh that's i i think if there was a
real media in this country
and in california especially they would
ask him that question which is a
governor do you have a death wish or
are you a a lying hypocrite which one
i think it's probably the lying
hypocrite one
number two a huge scandal here uh the
daily beast has this covered
it says madison cawthorne the north
carolina republican who became the
youngest member of congress in history
has admitted that he tried to convert
jews and muslims to christianity
my god in an interview with jewish
insider
the 25 year old who came under fire for
selfies he took at hitler's vacation
retreat in germany
claimed he had converted several muslims
to christ and several culturally jewish
people
catherine said if all if all you are is
friends with other christians then how
are you ever going to lead somebody to
christ
if you're not wanting to lead someone to
christ then you're probably not really a
christian
claiming he's read through just about
every single religious work there is
the republican said that he converted a
young woman from new york
and someone quote down in atlanta when
he was in rehab after a car accident
that left him paralyzed
it was pretty incredible carthorn added
as um
and said he has been unsuccessful in
converting practicing jews
but he has quote switched a lot of i
guess
culturally jewish people but being a
practicing jew like people who are
religious about it they are very
difficult i've had a hard time
connecting with them in that way
okay disturbing stuff
it seems that this evangelical christian
believes in evangelizing it seems that
this believer in the good news believes
in telling people the good news
it seems that this christian is
christian
incredible revelation i'm glad that
daily beast is on top of this
perhaps next we'll find out that you
know there are vegetarians out there who
like salad
uh bowlers who on occasion will roll
heavy balls towards
small stationary objects i mean it's
impossible to know what surprises
await us after this um by the way if
you've ever been just just a note here
if you've if you've ever if you've ever
been proselytized to
um whether you're a member of a
non-christian religion
or no religion you shouldn't be offended
by it or upset by it it doesn't make any
sense to be offended or upset by it
the person trying to convert you
believes they are telling you a crucial
truth about the
universe and reality um you may disagree
you know you may not believe what
they're saying but there's no place to
be offended by it
you should be offended if they don't
tell you if they don't share it with you
you know if you've got a christian in
your life who's who's uh
who's not sharing that with you i think
i think that
maybe is where the offense should come
in um
i think that tells you something about
how much they care about you
and for you it's sort of like you know
if you're if you're walking towards a
bridge
and someone thinks that the bridge is
faulty and it's going to give way if you
walk over it
they should tell you that and you should
be very offended
if they don't tell you that even if
they're wrong about the status of the
bridge
like you're walking over the bridge and
there's someone who sees you walking
they stay silent
and then as soon as you make it over
they shout to you oh phew
i thought that bridge was going to give
out well you would be right to respond
dude then why didn't you tell me that
before i walked across it
so you were prepared to just watch me
fall to my death
that's kind of what it's like but in
this case of course it's the other way
around where the christian believes
they're they are you know
they are pointing to a bridge that will
not give way
when they share the gospel they are
trying to steer you towards the sturdy
bridge
um and again even if you don't believe
what they're saying there's no cause
for offense any more than you know
in in other religions or some other
religions
there's not as much evangelizing that
goes on christianity is
uh somewhat unique on that front but if
i'm talking to someone of another
religion as has happened and they're
trying to convince
me of the truth of their religion
doesn't offend me at all
um all right let's go here and and
here's another not so shocking
revelation since we're on the subject of
things that shouldn't shock us another
hate crime claim
has been exposed as a hoax it says
um let's see this is from the daily wire
yes
clifton utzi 18 claimed that his bmw x5
was vandalized as part of a hate crime
with the perpetrator writing
every message that left-wing
provocateurs think the right believes
they spray-painted across the suv
racist and homophobic slurs including
the n-word and
kkk was sprayed across
the car as well as anti-black lives
matter messages
um i think there was a swastika
too but a month after the initial story
gained local media headlines i never
even heard about this
um the owner of the vehicle has now been
charged with multiple crimes in relation
to the incident
uh insurance fraud uh filing a flaw
false claim but bunch of other charges
it's good that they're actually being
charged with a crime for a change
because usually that's not how these
things go
uh he faces up to seven years in prison
no way he's actually gonna get seven
years in prison but i would like to see
that happen
if you really want to put an end to
these hate crime false hate crime
claims which seem to happen every week
now um there need to be
serious ramifications for people who do
this
and it is a serious crime you know to my
mind
if you file a false hate crime claim you
should get the penalty
that somebody would have gotten for
committing that hate crime if it had
really happened
so if somebody had actually defaced this
guy's car
with kkk and swastikas and you know
racial slurs and everything
then whatever whatever penalty they
would get and i'm sure it would be
several years in prison
that's the penalty that this person
should get to my mind
but this you know like like we talk
about where the
the uh the desire for
hate crimes and for racism uh
you know is there's a greater desire for
it than there is a supply of it
and it also just shows the people that
that that
come up with these fake hate crimes not
only
the fact that they're doing a fake hate
crime in the first place tells you
something
because if we really lived in a racist
country and you for some reason
wanted to be a victim of a hate crime uh
there should probably be plenty of
opportunities for it to really happen to
you
but it's not just that it's also just
that this would appear to be someone
who's just
never encountered an actual racist
person in their life
because they have no idea what an actual
racist person would say or how they
would act
that's what you find in the hate crime
hoaxers they they
it's not just that they've never been a
victim of a real hate crime it seems
like and this is good this is good news
they've never encountered actual racism
because they have no they have this
cartoonish idea
they get their idea of racism from tv
from the movies
like an actual racist person would spray
paint kkk
and a swastika on your on your card no
um so that's the good news we should we
should all we should all
be happy that racism is not nearly as
prevalent as the left likes to pretend
uh what else here from the new york post
it says americans who are hosting
gatherings over the holiday season
should encourage guests not to sing
while inside and should shield their
pets from interacting with guests
from outside their household according
to guidance from the cdc
the recommendations were included in a
list of guidelines by the agency to help
stop the spread of chronovirus as a
second wave
has spread like wildfire across the u.s
cdc is said encourage guests to avoid
singing or shouting especially indoors
keep music levels down so people don't
have to shout or speak loudly to be
heard
then it goes on from there with other
the cdc sounds like me talking to my
kids
no shouting keep the noise down hey no
jumping on the couches
those aren't trampolines um this is
obviously absurd but
i do have two thoughts here first of all
who who is singing at their holiday
parties do people
actually do that like in it's a
wonderful life
or something where the whole the whole
crowd starts singing together in unison
i've never seen i've heard music at
holiday parties i've been to plenty of
holiday parties in my life
i've never actually i don't think i've
ever actually seen a group of people
start singing
um number two i'm actually in favor
maybe this would surprise you um
i'm i'm in favor on a couple levels here
of this
first of all the thing about keeping
your pets away from the guests
totally in favor of that it's got
nothing to do with coving for me though
when i go over to your house and you
have a dog i'm sorry like i know you
love your dog and you think everyone
else does
i don't need your dog jumping on me
every five seconds it's super annoying
and it's always awkward when the person
who owns the dog is not
they just assume that we all they just
assume that i would just love to have
this slobbering beast crawling all over
me for the entire night
why would you assume i'd want that
um so that's that's good advice and the
second good advice i think is
banning singing and music at christmas
i'm actually in favor of that
as long as it's more targeted uh so
what i would say is ban certain songs
like ban
wonderful christmas time little drummer
boy
anything sung by mariah carey those
songs from what i understand
are um you know those are songs that
that if you sing them or listen to them
you're more at risk to spread covet i
think i think that's
that's the science they can also cause
bubonic plague hepatitis tetanus
so best to play it safe and ban just
those songs the rest of the christmas
music have at it
um number five finally i'm i'm concerned
about japan
very concerned um someone needs to have
a talk with japan
this it would appear is a very lonely
country
uh we already know about all the sex
robots in japan that's a big thing
last i read 67 of the population in
japan is now comprised of
sex robots um and i just made that up
but here's something i'm not making up
a new invention for single men in japan
here it is here you can see it it's a
robotic hand
which just to clarify the robotic hand
is uh
is is meant to simulate hand holding for
single guys
in japan and you see it says you could
take a romantic stroll with this robotic
head
it's uh if you can't see if you're if
you're listening to the audio podcast
it's a
it's like a severed hand um
but it's robotic and you kind of like
strap it to yourself
and it says it feels almost like a real
female hand supposedly
i'm not sure how much it costs the good
news is that at least
however much it costs it's sure to be
cheaper than an actual girlfriend so
that's the one positive
if you can deal with looking like a
serial killer when you walk down the
street
um then maybe this is the way to go i
just feel like
some other country needs to reach out to
japan at this point
and say like listen guys if you need a
friend
we could be pen pals you know this is
just
this is just not not healthy at all all
right we're gonna get to our speaking of
not healthy we'll get to our daily
cancellation in
just one second but before we do i want
to tell you about one of our new
responses on the show that we've been
talking about the last few weeks very
excited about
um acre you know it's it's really
important and as we're thinking about
the volatility and everything out there
it's really important to hedge your
investments with some gold but it's also
expensive to just go out and buy gold
that's not something that people are
necessarily equipped to do
so here's something new you know how the
price of gold has been skyrocketing
lately
there's a new way now to buy gold
through a company called
acre acre lets you subscribe to gold
bars for as little as 30 bucks a month
you pay each month and once your gold
stash reaches the price of their gold
bars they discreetly ship
acre gold to your house acre lets you
invest in physical gold
without coming out of pocket all at once
uh acre keeps you updated
on your gold stash every month and it
ships ships to you once you reach their
price
threshold and of course they're taking
care of your physical delivery and it's
going to be safe
it's going to come to you discreetly and
directly to your door so you've got
nothing to worry about acre designs
they're golden california they source
their gold from one of the largest mints
in switzerland
acre provides industry-first packaging
that uh
looks and feels more expensive than
other gold alternatives
acre just recently also by the way
introduced their new 100
a month subscription for their 5 gram
gold bar so you want to take advantage
of that also visit
getacregold.com walsh and start
investing in physical gold today
make sure you go to this url because
acre's also giving away a gold bar you
don't want to miss out on this
to qualify for the giveaway tweet or
post why you should be the recipient
and mention at get underscore acre
um to potentially get that free gold bar
as well
again that's get acre gold dot com walsh
and we want to thank acre gold
for support supporting uh the show also
one other quick note before we get to
the daily cancellation
uh if you were if you weren't already
disgusted by the legacy media i think
by now i'm sure you already were but if
you weren't i'm sure you are now
the media of course preemptively called
the election in favor of joe biden
and um they're you know claiming that
trump is undermining the elections by
not conceding
and now we're getting all these they
just sort of moved on from the election
and
and fraud claims and everything and
we're getting all these puff pieces
about
joe biden's dogs and uh camille harris's
husband i've seen multiple
stories about that could not be anything
less interesting to me
than the spouse of the potential vice
president
nothing could be less interesting but
we're getting stories like that
um if you're tired of all this and
you're tired of the narrative
that's why you should replace your cable
and your new subscriptions with the
daily wire
we've got big plans for the next four
years and beyond it starts today candace
owens
new york times bestselling author
founder of the blexa foundation is
joining the daily wire
she'll be launching a brand new show
with us early next year she'll be
writing for the
site as well we'll be building a an
entertainment channel
a new investigative journalism team
we'll have partnerships with
like-minded creators like prageru by the
end of the year we'll have all of their
um
their entire library will be available
on our website to members
and right now just so you know we're
serious we're offering 25 off all
memberships with code election
over at dailywire.com subscribe
members get all the perks that we always
tell you about articles ad free access
to all of our live broadcasts
the show library full three hours of ben
shapiro show if you become an all access
member you can participate in our
all-access
live discussions every night and
remember that's 25
off all memberships with code election
over at dailywire.com
subscribe replace the legacy media with
the daily wire
you won't regret it i guarantee it now
time for our daily cancellation
today for our daily cancellation we are
canceling canada
for this sign which appeared on a
canadian roadway
somewhere in that godforsaken country it
says do not
let moose lick your car
now so many questions arise at this
point first how do you stop a moose
from looking your car will a stern
scolding be enough
hey moose don't lick my car you hear me
moose i'm warning you
start shaking your fist and the moose is
like bro relax why would i lick your car
honestly this sign seems like it could
be propaganda to embarrass the moose
population
now everyone's going to assume that the
moose are a bunch of damned car lickers
it'd be kind of like if the government
put a sign outside your house that said
don't let the resident of this home run
outside and kiss you on the mouth
on one hand it's good advice i guess but
on the other hand it brands you in a way
that might be unfair
i'm also worried about something else
though okay this is important notice how
the sign
is in two parts it flashes do not let
moose
and you see that part and now you're in
suspense you're thinking don't let them
what
don't let the moose what what are the
moose up to now what dastardly scheme
and if the person driving by happens to
be british
uh the word let's can refer to renting
something out so they might think
it's telling them not to rent their
moose out to anyone
do not rent your moose out keep your
moose for yourself no moose renting
allowed
that could be confusing also
demoralizing for anybody in the
moose rental business but here's the
problem
then the sign flashes lick your car by
itself just lick your car
what if somebody catches only the second
half of the message driving by
all they see is lick your car and now
they think this is a directive
telling them to lick their cars to them
the sign reads like an instruction
lick your car do it now lick it lick the
car you freak you know you want to
we've learned that people are extremely
passive and obedient
especially canadians so there are
probably a whole bunch of people on that
road
licking their cars as they drive by not
knowing why
how long they're supposed to lick
imagine the traffic accidents that have
likely been caused
by people distracted by licking while
driving lwd
as the police call it imagine the
marital disputes
husband and wife driving by he sees the
signs she doesn't
he starts licking the dashboard she
looks at him what the hell are you doing
what the sign said lick my car what do
you want me to do
and listen my point here is not that
moose should be licking cars
or that we should allow them to frankly
moose have been getting away with
licking whatever they please for far too
long so in a certain way
i'm proud of canada for taking a stand
for once
and if anyone in canada can let me know
by the way what exact measures can be
employed to stop the moose from licking
please please tell me um it may come in
handy you know you never know
i might have a noose a moose knock on my
door tonight
like hey man can i uh can i lick your
car please i just gotta lick it i'm
jonesing
i'm jonesing for a taste of that car
fine one lick on the passenger side the
door handle
yeah right where my where my wife gets
in the car yeah right there
but this sign is just the wrong way to
handle the problem and for that
canada is canceled and for having this
problem at all
canada is canceled the rest of the world
is dealing with pandemics elections
war disease poverty canada is up there
just worried about
what the moose are licking so canada is
cancelled
also moose are cancelled any member of
any species
who licks cars is cancelled
and i am also canceled for the dumbest
daily cancellation
i've ever done it'll get dumber from
here i guarantee it
that's it today thanks for watching
everybody thanks for listening
godspeed
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical producer is austin stevens
edited by danny d'amico
and our audio was mixed by robin
fenderson the matt wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20.
hey everybody it's andrew clavin host of
the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
american republic is collapsing the
end of days is approaching and the moon
has turned to blood but on the andrew
clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way
through the apocalypse with me andrew
[Music]
clinton